this is the piece vitamin d deficiency
in cope at 19. make d while the sun
shines and when the sun doesn't shine
supplement
so
i began the piece right up front by
saying that vitamin d deficiency is so
widespread that many people are calling
it a
pandemic including many researchers
including even in the title of some
papers
and some researchers are are cautioning
you know what we don't know if what
we're looking at is um is causation or
just correlation and so maybe there
isn't really the problem that we think
it is and
one of those big reviews is actually
what we cited in our book a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century and so in the very the very top
paragraph and actually zach if you would
please put this back on the screen and
leave it up here while i'm talking about
this
um
of this of this piece
i say that although our our larger point
completely stands that we have our the
hyper novel world that we have lived in
which is of course the main theme of our
book
um is part of what is is making us
likely vitamin d deficient the fact that
we have indoor lifestyles the fact that
we are told to slather ourselves with
sunscreen whenever we go outside um is a
large part of what is making us vitamin
deficient
um but we
uh do not say don't supplement with
vitamin d in the book but we do say that
we think it's yet another example of the
sort of reductionist metric heavy
thinking that so much of modern science
and medicine is guilty of and both of us
have now on on this point at least on
the question of vitamin d
supplementation especially for those
living far from the equator have changed
our tune we have now seen enough
research and have talked to enough
people
that we think that vitamin d deficiency
really is something that is difficult to
escape from if a few other things are
true of you about which i'll say a
little bit more in a minute but you have
some yeah i just wanted to point out
what we did and didn't get right yeah um
our point in the book is that
supplements
do not appear to have a benefit if you
don't have a deficiency and therefore an
obsession with supplementing towards
some ideal uh state is unlikely to be
effective on the other hand what i think
has changed in our viewpoint is the
likelihood that you are deficient in
certain
uh nutrients well i would say um i would
say there's an additional point which is
that supplements
i you know isolate a particular thing
and you know when you take in for so
apparently something like 90 percent
across our species of our vitamin d
synthesis happens from exposure to the
sun specifically uvb rays
but there are dietary sources
and uh
you know largely fish eggs and organ
meats like liver are the primary dietary
sources
but for vitamin d like for you know
everything else that we get through our
diet
it is not necessarily and often is
guaranteed not to be as accessibly be as
bio available to us if we just take it
in some isolated form rather than with
you know in combination with the food in
which you would normally be getting it
which is then providing also the other
things that are necessary to you know
whatever it is open up the pathways that
allow it to to become part of you right
totally agree with this and in fact in
this case what we have um what you
unearthed your piece and what's evident
in all of the vitamin d literature is
that we have disrupted a very elegant
system and so for example
this is a fat soluble vitamin
it deposits in fat and so you can
imagine an ancestor who during the
plentiful times during the growing
season
is building up stores of vitamin d
uh in the sun
and then during lean times as they are
burning fat it would be released it's
effectively a time release mechanism
maybe i actually took out that that
exact
probably yes but there's more
complications that i'm not yet prepared
to go into here because there's there's
some questions about exact mechanism
fair enough in any case the point is um
you have a prediction that comes from uh
the supplementation question which is
if this is about dealing with deficiency
then the point is if you're not
deficient you don't need a supplement if
you are deficient you do need a
supplement but it's not entirely clear
how well that supplement works one of
the issues with vitamin d is can you
take it up right and so the fact that it
is in your diet doesn't necessarily mean
that it makes it into your physiology
and so that's a that's a question and
probably it would be wise if we all got
our vitamin d levels measured so we at
least even knew where we were right um
and then there's you know
there's also the issue which maybe
you'll get to but the idea of
we have stupid things like recommended
daily allowance right recommended daily
allowance doesn't say
summer
winter it doesn't pay heed to the idea
that this is actually a bankable vitamin
right and that all of these things
impinge on whether or not you should
look at a vitamin d supplement and think
that's something i might need or that's
something i don't need yeah now rda is
a
an overly simple metric the same way
that the idea of a universally best diet
for all humans is an overly simple
metric there can't actually be a number
for any molecule that actually you can
say that's the rda for all humans across
all ages across both sexes across all
races and health and and health
qualities uh there's no way right so we
have one that is for some you know it
used to be
i remember in the like in the 90s when
we were in grad school you would hear uh
you know so many of the recommendations
are just based on on men and
specifically white men and specifically
white men of a certain age and this this
is a risk and you know we actually know
this still for things like
heart attack now we're now not talking
about supplements here but most of the
signs the warning signs of heart attack
that people know of are actually typical
warning signs of heart attack for men
and typical signs of heart attack for
women are different
and um you know this this is this is a
true thing
and yet somehow we still seek the simple
universal rubric or a metric that we can
just carry around with us and exchange
with other people as if what is right
for us is inherently what is right for
them um i would just point out in
passing that in some sense the best
response
to
the woke claim
that the only cause for disparities in
outcome between populations is
oppression
vitamin d is the ultimate proof that
this isn't the case because
you're headed this way yeah yeah exactly
um so anyway i'll just say this the stem
for the idea is we different amount of
melanin based on where our ancestors
lived and that degree of protection from
uv radiation which is of course
damaging affects how readily you make
vitamin d in the sun so black people for
example
living in low latitudes have an obstacle
to producing enough vitamin d that
obviously isn't about oppression right
you mean high latitudes yes sorry um yes
yeah let's just let's just spell it out
and i do i do exactly spell this out in
the piece um that you know dark skin
color is exactly an adaptation uh to
tropical sun so that you don't burn and
the trade-off of not burning in the
tropical sun due to dark skin coloration
is that you synthesize vitamin d more
slowly
and in our global
world in our global economy when you
have lots of people moving around
compared to where our you know
intermediate level ancestors lived
pale skinned people fair-skinned people
going to the equator are much more
likely to burn
but their vitamin d synthesis is going
to be sky high and dark-skinned people
moving far from the equator are not
going to burn they're much less likely
to burn anywhere but they're much more
likely to be vitamin d deficient and so
uh one of the things that i started
thinking about when i was writing this
piece was all the comorbidities for
cobot 19 many of which maybe all of
which we've talked about on this on this
show on this podcast
um
are also conditions for which vitamin d
deficiency um
are
is is a known correlate and so let me
just walk through the i think it was
seven that i specifically pulled out
we have and you can show you are showing
my screen thank you zack
um
so as i say four of the most common
conditions associated with vitamin d
deficiency are also four of the most
severe comorbidities for coba 19 age
race obesity and kidney disease
so the older you are the the worse your
outcome from covet this is one of the
few things that everyone knows and
everyone seems to agree on even though
it's still you have occasional
social media tweets that ignore this
fact
but it's also true that the older you
get the less while you synthesize
vitamin d and older people are more
likely to be vitamin d deficient than
young people point one point two race
for exactly the reasons we were just
talking about we know that african
americans we've been hearing that
african americans have poorer outcomes
than european americans from from covid
and we've been you know we've been
some people have been trying to sell us
on the fact that this is due to uh
inequities in medical care and frankly
if you believe that it is entirely due
in equities and medical care at this
moment in 2021
then you really should not be in charge
of helping people because you are really
not thinking things through clearly it
is true that
because of the reasons that we just
spelled out the darker your skin the
less um the less quickly you synthesize
vitamin d and therefore the more you
need to spend time in the sun or and and
uh potentially eating a diet rich in
vitamin d rich foods although even those
foods
have a tiny percentage of ability to
get vitamin d into you as vitamin as sun
exposure does and or supplement
so i would just point out i do have the
other five to get through but okay i'll
just point out this isn't to say that
oppression couldn't cause the problem
right you could have lousy health care
in certain parts of town could not be
the only cause is my point right but the
point is because both of these things
point in the same direction yes right um
so an economic disparity and a
melanin skin
a sunscreen a built-in sunscreen that
blocks the production of vitamin d would
both point in the same direction this is
what people your and my age would call a
confound what people below 45 seem to
now call a con founder um but in any
case this is just something i've noticed
i'm going to stick with confound yeah i
think me too although i'm not entirely
convinced khan founder isn't
grammatically more correct but
but in any case i'm going to be stodgy
and they can just get the hell off my
lawn
but
too bad for them we don't have a lawn
right yeah
right yeah i care about no cheerios no
lawn yeah how are we doing we even cars
those are americans right how's that
yeah but
anyway so so the point is what you what
you what you've got is a situation which
you don't know what the contributing
what the contribution of uh melanin
versus uh disparities in health care is
but at the very least
it is insane to imagine that the only
cause would be oppression that to find
an outcome uh difference inherently
points to oppression is nonsense and you
know how many people
of any skin color know that skin color
actually affects the ability to
synthesize vitamin d in your skin
and that vitamin d is a
well-known uh correlate of so many
health outcomes i'm not going to go into
it here because we have a lot of other
things we want to do today but you know
go read this piece it's available for
free on my substance the number of
health conditions that are associated
with vitamin d deficiency is
extraordinary from cancers to uh to
immune response to infectious diseases
including influenza to other upper
respiratory viruses it is truly
extraordinary so
um let me just get through these top you
have something quick well i got one more
thing which is also notice that our
public health authorities do not
say politically incorrect things like
hey take a look at your skin
and you know depending upon how dark it
is we have a very different
recommendation based on you know based
on that how much lying in the sun you'll
probably ought to do right like how
often do they recommend lying in the sun
to anybody right in fact it's probably a
good idea anyway i would point out there
is an app which i have just become aware
of called d minder
which actually takes all sorts of
factors and uh it would be great if you
knew your d levels to start with which
it has a a field for but anyway it tells
you what hours of the day you're capable
of making vitamin d given where you are
given where you are on the planet right
it includes all these things including
skin color yeah great
um
yeah did we start
so i'm not going to go through the whole
piece here but you know i didn't say
i guess we did say the farther from the
equator you are the less capable of
synthesizing d um the closer to the
winter solstice it is um the harder it
is to synthesize d and add to that these
things which are
internal to who you are as opposed to to
the environment that you're in age
race
obesity the higher your bmi uh the less
good at synthesizing vitamin d from the
sun you are and the more likely you are
to be deficient and of course we know
that's one of the major comorbidities
for covid and then chronic kidney
disease is both a major comorbidity for
covid and
a um
at least a correlate of vitamin d
deficiency
and then uh these additional three
things and it's really it's really five
depending on how you count i was less
certain of the connection although um
i've since even since just posting this
on tuesday um have since learned more
and i'm growing more certain
both depression and anxiety disorders
both of which
are actually considered comorbidities
for coven 19 in this piece in this
massive article that we've talked about
in past episodes
um have been linked to vitamin d
deficiency so that's again both anxiety
disorders and depression
diabetes both type 1 and type 2
um is uh are understood to be downstream
of vitamin d deficiency not entirely you
know not it's not the only factor but
vitamin d deficiency is definitely a
cause in developing these things and are
both coveted comorbidities and then
being institutionalized like in a
nursing home or a care home is
associated with vitamin d deficiency
simply because you're very often not
even allowed outside and of course we
know
that nursing homes were um basically
super spreader places and you know
what's true of nursing homes at the very
least it's institutionalized old people
which brings two of these risk factors
right up close
so uh you know is there you know can we
say that vitamin d deficiency is causal
in bad covett outcomes uh some people
are saying that i am uh i am still
thinking on it but are there a ton of
correlations between the two conditions
and you actually have control you
everyone listening
if you have access to you know
a drug store to start
supplementing with vitamin d if you're
deficient yes you do so you know to the
degree that you can take control of your
own health do so
um
i would just finally point out that
there is some question about the causal
nature of sufficient d levels in
resistance of covid but it is
a
probable that d
is
causally protective that sufficient
levels of d are protective but the key
thing
and this is an argument that has been
made by several people we made it um
others
some of whom we know have also made it
for various other substances but there
is a pascal's wager issue at the very
bottom of this yes which is to say
that the risk
the likelihood that you are d deficient
is incredibly high the number of things
that d seems to be protective of is
incredibly
large
the harm to you if you raise your d
levels and it somehow turned out that d
was a third correlate and not causal is
so low the cost of the stuff is very
cheap the danger of taking way too much
of it is very low
and um the potential benefit is sky high
and so the point is
you might as well but then the real
import of that is
to the extent that our public health
authorities
are not recommending this have not been
recommending it throughout the pandemic
you know that they are either
incompetent at a level that strains
graduality or not interested in health
and until they change their tune on this
i think one has to look at everything
they say with a kind of skepticism how
do i know this person is actually
interested in my health the way they
claim to be if they are not picking the
lowest hanging fruit on the tree which
is vitamin d
and you know that's a jaw-dropping thing
to say public health officials who
aren't interested in in health public or
otherwise uh that's a remarkable claim
on the other hand
how else are we to explain
their total silence on vitamin d
[Music]